I am ranking the top 100 secrets most people
don’t know about One Piece. And if you want
to see if you are a true one piece expert,
keep watching all the way to number one to
see how many of these you actually know.
And we’ll start with our first mind-blowing
fact, which is that the anime completely skipped
the crucial first chapter of the manga until
episode four, leaving first time viewers unaware
of Luffy’s backstory.
Which might sound crazy, but that’s just
the beginning because Nami, not Luffy, was
the first Straw Hat to appear in the anime,
looking fabulous while undercover on a random
passenger ship.
However, there is absolutely no way she would
be able to sneak around undercover if Oda
stuck with Nami’s original design. That’s
because in her first design she had both a
mechanical arm AND foot, plus she had this
totally badass battle ax. Personally, I’m
super curious how this would have changed
her journey in the story
Though I bet you never realized that Nami
and Robin are the only crew members to betray
Luffy. Nami stole the ship and Robin framed
the crew for assassination. Seriously, don’t
mess with these women.
What’s even more incredible is that many
of the most famous pirates in One Piece have
real world inspirations. Blackbeard and Whitebeard
were clearly inspired by the real Edward Teach,
also known as Blackbeard, but Roger’s famous
execution scene was inspired by a French pirate
who gave a famous puzzle during his execution.
Among many others, the silky smooth Alvida
has a real life counterpart, as does Jewelry
Bonney and even Rocks D. Xebec, who was inspired
by a Brazilian pirate.
And from some of the most important pirates
in the story, let’s discuss some of the
most secret. This funny guy is Pandaman, a
character that Oda often draws in the background
of chapters. While Pandaman may appear as
a simple gag, he possesses a full backstory,
complete with a lover, a rival, and a gang
to whom he owes money.
But Pandaman is not the only recurring gag
character. This is Manatomo, the traveling
carpenter who specializes in fixing broken
things. One of his notable repairs involved
the door to the bar, which had been broken
way back in chapter 1.
And we can’t forget about Sam, this bald
drunkard who sometimes shows up having had
a few too many drinks.
Amazingly, Sanji and Brook actually had strikingly
similar introductions. Both wore a black suit
and held hot liquid. That was soup for Sanji
and Coffee for Brook. Plus they are the most
perverted on the crew, so I am super curious
what other similarities we might learn in
the future.
That’s not the only insane hidden fact about
Brook, because he is officially the only straw
hat to never meet either of Luffy’s brothers,
Sabo and Ace.
Which might seem crazy but did you know that
among all the characters in one piece this
massive man, Urogue, embodies the essence
of a true pirate with his hobbies. These include
traveling, drinking, and, well... um lovemaking.
But who would want to— *Shakes* head, wave
hands No. No. I really don’t even want to
think about it.
While Urogue may be getting plenty on the
side, the same can't be said for Kid and Killer.
And that’s because they once shared a childhood
crush, but when they laughed at her for spilling
curry, she promptly beat the shit out of them.
So much for punk rock love.
But the same can’t be said for Blackbeard
because these two ladies we see hanging off
him are called Tori and Maki, which if you
put them together is Torimaki. And in Japanese
this roughly translates to gold digger, who
is a woman who sleeps with men for their money.
On the other hand, one pirate who’s definitely
not getting the ladies, is this cat-loving
fake butler. And that’s because Oda has
officially confirmed that these weird little
golden blobs on his jacket are actually meant
to be poop.
However, make fun of him at your own risk
because he backs a serious punch. In fact,
you might not know that the former Marine
Captain Morgan once tried to capture Kuro,
but the cat pirate broke his jaw which is
why Morgan has this metal mouthpiece.
As unlikely as it may sound, Kuro isn’t
even the weirdest member of his crew. That
honor belongs to Jango, who has this weird
stem looking facial hair. But it turns out
that this is not even hair. Instead Oda has
confirmed that it is the stem of a mushroom
that somehow started growing on Jango’s
face
Amazingly, what is not fake is this god damn
luxurious facial hair. However, what you might
not know about Gol D. Roger’s famous mustache
is that Oda originally planned for this to
just be super long nose hairs. Yikes. Kinda
gross.
And while Ace didn’t inherit his father’s
impressive facial hair, he is actually the
only known character in the story to reject
an invitation to join the World Government’s
Warlords.
Now, have you ever wanted to have Luffy’s
courage? Or magically learn his ability to
never get nervous? Well, you might want to
reconsider after you hear THIS. According
to the author of One Piece, Luffy is only
like this because he is a complete idiot who
doesn’t know any better.
But okay, okay, even if you knew that fact,
did you know that we almost had THIS in the
story. That’s right, Sanji was originally
planned to be called Naruto, but since the
Naruto that we all know and love was becoming
its own popular manga at the time, Eiichiro
Oda, the author of One Piece, decided to change
his name to avoid confusion.
Alright, so far that’s 20 facts. Did you
know all of those? Well even if you did, I
bet you didn’t know that…
The pirate empress Boa Hancock actually appeared
on a cover of Shonen Jump all the way back
in 1999? That’s nine whole years before
her introduction in the story.
You might not know she’s not even the only
character to appear in a magazine. That’s
because in chapter 762, Law’s mentor, Corazon
is reading a newspaper that shows the Warlord
Crocodile. Apparently this article was praising
Crocodile’s heroism for hunting down pirates
during his early years as a Warlord.
While the incredible recent events of Cross
Guild have Crocodile teaming up with the world’s
strongest swordsman, here is a little known
fact about Mihawk. Apparently, he was famous
even before Roger’s execution began the
Great Pirate Era. Which makes me super curious
what he was doing during all this time. And
as we discussed in a recent chapter review,
it's actually possible that he might have
been working for the Celestial Dragons.
This next fact goes back even before the Celestial
Dragons existed. And that’s because the
earliest event that we have an official date
for is the Golden Age of Shandora, which was
stated to occur during the early 402 which
is about 1100 years before the current story.
This next fact is just as incredibly old.
And that’s because the animal mink tribe
has lived on the back of this giant elephant
for over 1000 years, which means that they
were outcasts even before the void century.
However, would you believe me if I told you
there is an even more secret and mysterious
elephant than Zunesha? Listen to this. The
new warden of impel down has a strange obsession
with underwear? In fact, Oda shows us his
collection in a question corner, including
this one called, Mr. Elephant. eh-hem *starts
typing, whispers off screen*. Where can I
get one of those… oh, right, back to the
video.
What’s even crazier though is that Shanks
has been putting his own Mr. Elephant to work.
In the cover of chapter 614, we see the bartender
Makino holding this young child. When asked
who the father of this child was, Oda simply
replied that it is probably “that man”,
which strongly suggests that it is Shanks,
since the Red Hair captain visits her bar
often, as we see in the very first chapter.
What’s even more interesting is that the
Straw Hat's ship, the Thousand Sunny, hides
a locked freezer with a passcode? Only Sanji,
Nami, and Robin know the combination, which
is based on their birthdays.
The Thousand Sunny also boasts a surprising
library. Every Straw Hat pirate, except Luffy,
has at least one book in the collection. Even
Zoro enjoys looking at books about swords
and Jinbe likely added books about the seas
after joining.
On the other hand, do you want to know the
most disgusting fact about the ship? The men
rarely use the toilet. Instead, they do their
business off the side. Which was actually
common for sailors, and many boats had "crap
lines" on the ship to help sailors avoid falling
overboard.
Now, instead of food going out, let’s talk
about one man who knows how to appreciate
his comfort food. That’s because this guy,
Vergo, finds comfort in a daily breakfast
routine of hamburgers, fries, and a strawberry
milkshake.
But one thing he apparently won’t eat is
devil fruits, because he is the only one of
Doflamingo’s officers to not have eaten
a devil fruit.
Next is a fact you’ll definitely only know
if you are a die hard Sanji fan. That’s
because over the entire 1000 plus chapters,
Zoro has never called Sanji by his proper
name in the original Japanese manga.
And while many fans assume that the two hate
each other, they actually care about each
other quite a lot. They have proven that they
will even risk their lives to save the others,
such as in Thriller Bark and in Wano.
Which means that this next fact could have
completely ruined the best bromance in manga.
That’s because this fierce rivalry almost
never existed. Originally, Zoro was planned
to be a simple bodyguard for Buggy, meaning
he would have been left behind long ago.
Though honestly I would love to see how the
story would change if some of Oda’s craziest
ideas were included, so make sure to subscribe
to the channel if you want to see a future
video on that topic.
This next fact shows us just how sneaky Oda
can be. That’s because Oda has included
his name and the title of the story on various
books throughout the story, including episode
21, 70, and 278.
While you might be frantically looking back
through the story now, stick around because
you won’t believe these incredible facts
about Dressrosa that you probably missed.
Like, did you know that this samurai never
actually received a bounty from the Doflamingo
family. And that’s because Kanjuro was actually
working for Doflamingo’s bosses all along.
In Dressrosa, we also meet the Tontatta dwarves,
who live on Greenbit. But did you ever realize
that the famous explorer Noland, who we met
in the Skypiea flashback actually found the
dwarves during his travels.
Even if you knew that, I bet you never realized
that this snow harpy lady was actually the
very first female character to die in the
main story, not including flashbacks.
Here is another unbelievable fact about other
Logia fruit users. Every one of these powerhouses
that were introduced before the time skip,
was present during the war at Marineford,
except the lightning fruit user, Enel.
What’s even crazier about Enel is that he
was actually the first major antagonist who
was not either a pirate or a marine.
Putting slim shady aside, out of all of these
extremely powerful devil fruit users at Marineford,
the very first one introduced into the story
was Smoker, who was also the first marine
shown with a devil fruit all the way back
in Logue Town.
But while we wait and pray for another epic
clash like Marineford in the future, we do
already know the winner of one of Usopp’s
most important battles in the story. And that’s
because Usopp’s nose is confirmed to be
just slightly longer than this guy’s.
Speaking of appearances, have you ever noticed
that these three brothers all have incredibly
unique hats? I mean come on, why doesn’t
anyone else in the story have such epic headwear?
While it’s hard to believe that Luffy has
the best hat game in the entire series, it's
worth noting that Zoro, Sanji, and Nami each
hold a different important title—they are
the only ones in their twenties among the
crew. Zoro and Sanji are twenty-one, while
Nami adds her youthful charm at twenty.
Although Zoro is in that honorable club, Zoro
also stands alone as the only member of the
Worst Generation without a devil fruit. This
guy also never had a devil fruit, until he
was technically forced to eat an artificial
devil fruit during the Wano arc.
Shifting gears to a completely different setting,
let's delve into some mind-blowing revelations
about the prisoners residing in the underwater
prison, Impel Down. First is that Mr. 2 somehow
survived his fight with the venomous warden
and is now the new ruler of New Kama land.
What’s even crazier is that while Mr. 2
is still in prison, another former enemy was
once set free. That would be the fishman Arlong,
who is the only individual we know to have
ever been released from Impel Down. This was
only allowed because Jinbe agreed to join
the Warlords and demanded that his fishman
brother be released.
Then we have this insanely strong former prisoner,
Daz Bones, who is actually the only confirmed
bounty hunter to have ever eaten a devil fruit
However, during the chaos of Impel Down Daz
Bones escaped with Luffy and went to fight
a Marineford. But did you know that the war
at Marineford introduced the first two Mythical
Zoan fruits into the story. During this battle
we saw not only Marco’s Mythical Phoenix
fruit, but also the fleet admiral Sengoku’s
Mythical Golden Buddha fruit.
Still feeling great about your random one
piece knowledge? Or are you just along for
the ride at this point? Either way, let’s
jump into the second half of our Hidden Facts
Ranking!
Going right back to insanely overpowered devil
fruits, we now have nine mythical Zoans in
the story. But you might not realize that
a shocking six of them were revealed during
the Wano arc. Those nine are the Yamata no
Orochi fruit, Kaido’s Mythical fish fruit,
this shape-shifting Onyudo fruit, Caterina
Devon’s Nine-tailed fox fruit, Yamato’s
wolf deity fruit, and, of course, Luffy’s
Nika fruit.
That means that the only other Mythical Zoan
revealed outside of Marineford and Wano is
the Mythical Peagasus fruit, which was recently
shown by the horse Stronger during the Egghead
Island ar.
Though all of these mythical Zoans are absurdly
powerful, you might not have realized that
basically none of them are as strong as Akainu’s
magma fruit. In fact, did you know that Akainu’s
powers are so strong that he was able to destroy
one of Aokiji’s legs and leave him with
burns all along his arm?
Now, let's shift our focus to another mind-blowing
example of foreshadowing. Did you know that
in the anime, Zoro gave Luffy a striking X
scar on his chest that was incredibly similar
to the scar he received from this magma fist.
Talk about incredible foreshadowing, even
in a filler episode!
Speaking of foreshadowing, did you know that
Sanji gave himself the nickname “Mr. Prince”
in Little Garden it was actually foreshadowing
Sanji’s true lineage as a prince of the
Vinsmoke
While it took over six hundred chapters for
that foreshadowing to pay off, Jinbe is also
another example of Oda’s incredible long
term planning. That’s because he was directly
mentioned way back in chapter 69, but was
not officially revealed in the manga until
a staggering 459 chapters later.
On the other hand, Robin burst in without
any invitation at all. In fact, she is the
only straw hat who Luffy did not invite to
join the crew.
Now, do you know who he said are the hardest
characters to draw? That would be the most
beautiful woman in the world, Hancock, and
also the mermaid princess Shirahosi. Hmm,
I wonder why?
Sticking with our favorite mangaka, Oda once
shared that if he could choose a Devil Fruit
power, he'd opt for Robin's Hana Hana no Mi
so that he could have more hands to draw the
story. Personally, I’d probably choose the
Phoenix fruit, but Robin’s is cool too.
Now let’s get to some truly unbelievable
facts about the world of One Piece and it’s
creators. First, did you know that One Piece
was only supposed to last for five years.
*chuckles*, whoops.
On top of that, the Warlords were never planned
to exist in the story. Oda had originally
only planned for Luffy to only fight the Yonko.
So goodbye, to all of you chumps.
That’s not even all of the major factions
who randomly became a part of the story, because
Oda famously made up the entire group of Supernova
pirates at the very last minute before they
appeared in the story.
Which is hard to believe, but did you also
know that Nami is the only straw hat to invite
someone else onto the crew before Luffy did.
This happened in chapter 140, she asked Chopper
if he wanted to come along on their grand
adventure.
And while the Chopper we know and love is
an adorable reindeer, Oda almost gave us THIS
SHOCKING DESIGN. Yeah, so this cuddly reindeer
was almost a chain smoking Zebra-reindeer
hybrid instead. It’s actually pretty incredible
how much some of the crew changed from their
original designs.
Similarly, did you know that Chopper's current
design was inspired by the most famous reindeer
of all?Chopper just has a blue nose instead
of red, and his birthday is even on Christmas
eve.
We all know Chopper’s goal is to save lives,
but he isn’t the only merciful member of
the crew. Surprisingly, Luffy has never actually
killed a major opponent in the series – except
maybe Kaido, but that part is a little unclear.
But this is actually an intentional choice
because Oda believes that crushing someone’s
dream is a fate even worse than death.
However, that’s far from the only major
hidden secret Luffy has up his sleeve. In
fact, we all know that Luffy wants to become
king of the pirates, but that’s actually
only one part of his true dream. However,
we're left in the dark about this secret wish,
but every time he has told someone in the
story, they usually think it is quite amusing.
Now, I want you to pause and think about this:
what is the most disturbing scene in all of
One Piece? Do you have it in mind? Well, you’re
probably wrong. That’s because of this scene
during the final battle of the One Piece movie:
Baron Omatsuri and the Secret Island. And
I won’t spoil it for you, but it was so
awful that it nearly wiped out the entire
crew.
If that’s hard to think about, just wait
because that’s not even the most tragic
fact about One Piece. A number of the anime
voice actors have passed away during the run
of the show. These include voice actors for
Jinbe, Rayleigh, Mihawk, Sengoku, Smoker,
Gol D. Roger, and a few more. And it genuinely
makes me sad that they’ll never get to reach
the end of Luffy’s journey.
Unsurprisingly, Oda is just as emotionally
invested in the story as we are. In fact,
he often finds himself moved to tears by his
own scenes such as bidding a tearful farewell
to the beloved Going Merry or witnessing Vivi's
desperate pleas for peace in Alabasta.
Now let’s stick with Luffy a little longer
with some quick hitter hidden facts. Ready?
Let’s go. Did you know that Luffy only bathes
once a week?
Or that he is the youngest member of the worst
generation of pirates
And that Luffy has ranked first in every single
One Piece popularity poll?
Plus another completely bizarre fact is that
Luffy, Usopp, and Sanji all claim to have
never been sick, so they don’t actually
know what it feels like to have those cold
symptoms. I mean, Luffy’s been poisoned
plenty of times, and he’s always survived,
so maybe he just has a ridiculous immune system.
As for Sanji and Usopp, well, that’s a bit
more debatable if they are telling the truth
or just trying to show off.
Now, let's rewind to Luffy's childhood, where
he befriends Sabo in the class-divided Goa
Kingdom. But the surprise comes when their
paths cross again in Dressrosa, which is yet
another kingdom plagued by class divisions
with a peculiar twist—its lower-tier citizens
are transformed into literal toys.
In addition, just like when Luffy smashed
Doflamingo into the ground, did you know that
there is one thing that ALWAYS happens after
Luffy takes down a major antagonist? No, it’s
not a party, but we do always see Luffy crack
that characteristic big grin within one or
two chapters after taking down the big bad
guy.
What’s even crazier though is that Luffy
certainly deserves those smiles, because he
and the rest of the straw hats have all lost
someone significant to them in their past.
Parents, mentors, brothers. No one is safe
from the Straw Hat’s pasts.
As strange as that is, did you know that the
Marines aren’t the only branch of the World
Government’s Military? As we can see on
this wanted poster drawn by Oda, there is
clearly Coast Guard written instead of Marines.
So since the Coast Guard does exist, I wonder
if they have a special dish they eat every
week? Because apparently, the Marines’ Friday
tradition is to eat a very special dish called
Marine Curry.
Even that is not as surprising as Robin’s
other job on the Straw Hat crew. That’s
because Robin is also one of the straw hat’s
hair stylists. We learned this in a question
corner when Oda said that Usopp and Robin
cut the crew’s hair, and then after the
timeskip, Sanji was added to the hair cutting
team.
And much to everyone’s surprise, the World
Government was actually more desperate to
get their hands on one particular object than
they were about capturing fearsome pirates
like Kaido, Shanks, and Big Mom. This object
is the Ope Ope no Mi, and they were willing
to pay a staggering 5 billion berries to recover
it before Law consumed its powers.
Shifting from one of the most valuable things
in the story, let’s meet the weakest. Do
you know who it is? Well, that would be Batchee,
the small cricket that was unfairly squished
by this marine during the Baratie arc.
This brings us to a few more incredible facts
about the straw hats themselves. Oda once
confirmed that Nami was the third smartest
character we had seen in the East Blue, only
behind these two. However, with Nami's growth
throughout the story, it wouldn't be surprising
if her ranking has improved since then
Here's a fact straight from the author himself:
Usopp will forever hold the title of the weakest
Straw Hat, regardless of who joins the crew.
This distinction arises from Usopp's relatability
to normal people, while his crewmates all
have extraordinary powers
What very few people actually know is that
Usopp actually has his own hidden superpower?
That’s because many of Usopp’s lies from
the very first chapter have actually come
true. He found the emerald city, met a mole,
encountered the three headed dog, fought a
dragon, and even survived a giant goldfish.
But no Usopp fact is more important than his
birthday, which is actually on April 1st.
This is hilariously appropriate because April
1st is April Fools' Day in many parts of the
world.
What not a joke is the real-life inspiration
behind the revolutionary army.Dragon's ship,
as the Wind Granma, is based on a historical
yacht that played a significant role in transporting
rebel soldiers aiming to overthrow a former
Cuban president. Sound familiar?
The most heart-warming fact about Robin is
that before Enies Lobby, she did not call
any of the straw hat crewmates by name. Instead
she called them by titles such as “Navigator”
or “Cook”. And this was because she never
let herself be fully accepted as a true member
of the crew until the Straw Hats saved her
from the World Government
Just like Robin, even Oda needs to feel accepted
sometimes. And one important milestone for
him was passing the number of chapters in
the legendary original Dragon Ball manga.
This occurred in chapter 519, and to mark
the achievement, Oda included special shading
and tone on the cover page.
But one fact that is almost too shocking to
believe is about Sanji’s eyebrows. And that’s
because when Sanji actually used the super
powered raid suit during his fight in Wano,
his curly eyebrows literally changed direction
to match his brothers. This was hugely symbolic
because Sanji’s eyebrows have always been
different to show that he is more human than
his emotionless brothers. However, once Sanji
rejected the raid suit later on, his eyebrows
turned back to their normal form.
And now into the top 10 most secret, crazy,
astonishing facts about One Piece.
We all know that chapter 1 is also the moment
where Luffy stabs himself which results in
his famous scar. But did you ever notice that
Luffy’s Grandpa and Father also have noticeable
marks on the left side of their faces. Garp
has a scar and Dragon has this tattoo. Surely
this must have some meeting, and I’ll give
you another hint about its true importance
in the very last fact of this video.
While this is one crazy family, it is nowhere
near as insane as the biggest family in the
story. That’s because Big Mom has been somehow
giving birth for 42 STRAIGHT YEARS! She has
had 43 husbands which have produced 39 daughters
and 46 sons. Yeesh. Somewhere my Mom is in
pain just thinking about 46 little Manu’s
running around the house.
What you didn’t know about Big Mom's strongest
son, Katakuri, is that he’s also officially
the biggest donut lover in the entire story.
In fact, he may hold the record for the most
donuts consumed in a row, a feat that even
Garp attempted to beat by devouring a staggering
834 of them. Umm, hello, where can I sign
up for this donut-eating championship? Custard
Cream for me, please.
Now, do you know which of the most iconic
scenes of the story was almost erased by a
real-life natural disaster? That would be
this one. That’s right, we almost never
got to see Blackbeard show off his new powers
in the anime because during this time, a massive
earthquake triggered a tsunami that caused
immense damage in Japan. This scene from the
anime aired only weeks before this disaster,
but I have to wonder if they would have taken
it out had the tsunami had happened before
the scene in the anime.
At number six, did you know there is one One
Piece fan who absolutely knew how One Piece
ended? That’s because one young fan who
had lung cancer asked the Make a Wish Foundation
if he could learn the end of One Piece. So
Oda agreed to fulfill the kids last request,
and revealed how One Piece would end to the
one fan alone. So thank you Oda-sensei, for
granting wishes with your incredible story.
What’s crazy about One Piece is that sometimes
it is super easy to forget the actual timeline
of the story. Like, can you believe that the
first half of the story unfolded within a
mere four months in the One Piece world? So
Luffy went from this to this in the same time
it takes to complete a semester of school.
Wow, what are we doing with our lives…
And did you know that Sabo might actually
have been revealed back in chapter 98. That’s
because right here we can see a character
in a black suit and hat who looks just like
Sabo. He shows up again right here. And it
would make sense that Sabo is here because
Dragon, the leader of the revolutionary army,
also shows up to save Luffy.
Another shocking fact is that two of the most
god-like, and popular, characters in the story
have never actually met. If you don’t know,
I’m talking about the god of lies, Usopp,
and the hero who fails his way to the top,
Buggy the Clown.
Now, this next fact is going to make you completely
rethink who the strongest straw hat is. And
that’s because Nico Robin had an even higher
bounty than the strongest creature in the
world, Kaido, when they were both the same
age as children.
That means for the absolute most insane hidden
fact in all of one piece is the secret symbol
of the left eye. Throughout the story, Oda
has drawn many characters with their left
eye closed including these volume covers.
The symbol also shows up on the map of Jaya
and even on this abstract painting in Dressrosa.
And I bet you can’t even imagine just how
much this symbol reveals about where to find
Laugh Tale, what the ancient kingdom was,
and how the future of the story will go.
And just to top it off, here is one last bonus
fact. Did you know who is the only character
who rejected the chance to join both Gol D.
Roger and the Straw Hat crew as a kid? That
would be Franky, and if you want to know exactly
why he initially rejected both crews, you
can watch this video right here.
Shanks for Watching